it's in the preliminaries where is
magnus carlton
he's making the moves there and he seems
to be repeating the same strategy that
he did in game one yep the invisible man
magnus carson and right now it's pretty
much the exact same position as he had
against artemiev
and in that position
magnus pushed his pawn forward and it's
the same again last time we saw artemiev
capture this white pawn but long term 40
moves down the line we saw white's extra
central pawn come in handy and actually
abductor of repeating the exact same
opening did you look at magnus carlsen's
previous game is this something he
studied before or is he freestyling we
will find out
this is slightly different to the last
game but it might well transpose back to
carlson against artemiev right now i'm
expecting magnus to go and capture that
black pawn with the white knight on the
edge of the board and very level
position but magnus clearly likes these
types of uh
these types of pawn structures so let's
see whether abdusatorov can handle it
better than vladislav television
and temporarily we see a picture of
magnus while he tries to sort out his
camera
in the last game magnus was quite keen
on setting up with what we call a double
fianchetto so that means pushing the
white b pawn forward one square in order
to create a nice uh diagonal for the
white dark squared bishop ivanka do you
think we'll see the repetition of that
is it surprising to you that magnus has
played the same opening twice in a row
he nearly never does that
yeah it's it's not surprising to me
because i think that he's just trying to
play for a game with no
no risk you know
and uh yeah he had a pleasant position
out of the opening i mean i wouldn't say
it was anything more than equal but
still it was okay he can play the moves
our tempo and to be honest
naughty back would probably have had
what five minutes to prepare yeah that's
not enough
possibly not um abductor did finish his
game quite quickly i think in the last
round so he maybe he was watching that
game that magnus was still playing i
think maybe he had 20 30 minutes to
prepare also possibly he had a coach
watching magnus's game being like okay
magnus has played this opening it's not
great if you do this you'll have a fine
position yeah so yeah it's surprising to
me um although magnus has admitted for
example in our podcast um that these
days he's reliant more on openings than
before in opening preparation and he
does repeat the same idea doesn't repeat
the same idea i mean one approach that i
take because i play a lot of the same
stuff you know always the same opening
is that i'm just like well you know i've
actually studied this for
say 15 hours you've started it for half
an hour i think i went oh but we have a
change yep the first new move of the
game so uh white instead of bringing his
bishop out to the longest possible
diagonal uh he's pushed the bishop two
squares so last time we saw magnus just
move that bishop one square now two
squares he's attacking black's pawn on
the c5 square with his dark squared
bishop and this one looks a bit
surprising black can defend that pawn in
a few ways but
maybe magnus is trying to ask a question
he's trying to set a trap because if
abdusatorov defends this weak pawn this
undefended pawn uh in the most natural
way by pushing forward here then
suddenly look at this bishop it's opened
up and white knight for example could
spring forward and
suddenly there's pressure there's some
real problems along this diagonal um we
could see a trade of knights here and
the black rook is under fire if it moves
the white knight could spring forward
once again with a double attack what we
call a fork
and uh yeah this would spell danger for
abductor of so that being said uh maybe
he can defend the pawn in a different
way not the most natural way not the
move he wants to play um this b6 move
because of the white bishop opening up
but instead possibly we'll see him
retreat his knight defending this pawn
but also opening up his own bishop this
type of position is all about those
bishops on their long diagonals and uh
this is the move i'm expecting to see
i'm slightly
curious about what magnus intends here
okay he brings the knight into a
different
yeah
yeah i was actually going to say that
this was the for me the most natural
move because i
your move was actually top computer
choice yeah i think i've studied that
exact position before but maybe that's
why but uh why does this move appeal to
you it defends this pawn opens up there
because because because and uh actually
i think this is uh maybe a slight
inaccuracy from black because yes okay
it attacks the rook but the rooks uh the
knights are not secure in their posts
and the reason why instinctively i
perhaps would not have retreated the
night because i would have been
stressing for a long time about this
light square bishop that black has maybe
it gets just trapped on this on the
sideline and will never get out yeah so
if you've gone the other way to the
square i suggested maybe this bishop is
not so happy that's why abduce a tour of
true is a different square but now after
magnus moved his rook uh centralized his
rook as you mentioned this knight is
slightly loose totally loose and also
that pawn that other bishop on a3 is
attacking it's also loose yep exactly
once this knight gets kicked away this
pawn will suddenly be falling and
um yeah i i've had so much experience on
this type of position with white and
black and i hate putting my knights on
these types of squares because now
it might be a target for white's bishop
it might be a target from white's queen
it might just get hit by a pawn black is
going to have to lose time with that
knight sooner or later this piece looks
nice and active it's in white's half but
it's going to have to get kicked back
at some point so okay abdus the torah
played that quite quickly is this part
of his opening preparation does he have
a plan in mind or will we see him
suddenly realize that this knight is a
target for white i think magnus has just
been very sneaky and tricked abdusatorov
into a worse position i mean it's not
it's not
losing for here for abductor of just
simply magnus has a very very
comfortable position and all to do with
the power of the light square bishop
yeah and this is uh to do with what you
were saying earlier ivanka so you
specialize in this
a set number of openings and you know
them inside out you've got so much
experience with them and actually magnus
repeating what he did in the first round
but just a tiny change has maybe
confused his opponent and that's that's
why i often recommend your approach just
specializing in one opening you know all
the different move orders you know all
the different tricks as long as you
you're not too predictable as long as
you vary every now and then sometimes
you catch your opponent out and do
satoru it doesn't look too happy now i
have to say on that subject you know
i've made it a point that i've been
studying now for two weeks in a row on
chassis ball like my kara khan opening
and i've every day i've been
studying this one specific variation and
trying to get the nuances in so you know
and even then i get my move orders
modeled but you know every time i
practice it gets better and better and
i'm just
how deep are we talking we're talking
pretty deep yeah we're talking we're not
talking like the first five no we're not
talking the first five news we're
talking about something very complicated
yeah and we're talking about like these
really wild positions where you have to
know where things go and you have to
know about those opportune moments and
uh that's what i've been doing and i'm
like now like come on
someone play this line against me
okay meanwhile we do have a move from
the uzbek grand master he's brought his
knight forward so both black knight's
actually sitting in white's half
and that knight can be captured that
black knight is actually hitting white's
pawn in the corner white's a pawn
it's hard to defend that guy so i'm
expecting white to trade off that his
dark square bishop for that black knight
black would have to recapture with the
pawn meaning he has doubled pawns but in
return black does gain the advantage or
what we regard as an advantage of the
bishop pair so
very logical abductors last move maybe
it was forced maybe there was just no
other option
to keep black's position intact so
rather than just sit still and try and
kind of push pawns protecting everything
which wouldn't have worked he has leapt
forward with his knight and he's trying
to be a bit more dynamic it's one thing
i've noticed about abdu satoru from
maybe what makes him stand out amongst
all of the talented teenagers these days
is that he is quite dynamic and
yeah he often does take risks and he
backs them up he justifies those risks
with tactics yeah so yeah interesting
move one thing i i noticed about
abdusatorov especially in the world
rapid championship is that he was so
resilient he found himself in so many
lost positions and he kept surviving and
he turned those games around you know
and he defeated a whole string of top
grand masters you know it wasn't just
magnus it was also fabiana caruana
lebron ironian boris girlfriend you know
it was like a whose chairs
and he just seemed
so mentally strong like even after
winning it was just oh yeah yeah i won
but now i need to focus on the next
thing you know it
didn't seem to bother him at all that he
had just won a world championship and
one thing i noticed from the video was
towards the final stages he actually
seemed pretty nervous
i mean he didn't look like he was super
calm and i i was really impressed by how
he controlled those emotions to go on
and just defeat magnus so that was very
very impressive and here you know he's
using his resourcefulness now just
trying to find the most dynamic solution
um yeah i like bishop takes knights yeah
maybe we can jump in just to see what
might happen over the next few moves um
so we're expecting as you mentioned
bishop takes knight this knight cannot
be allowed to live too much longer
because it is attacking a pawn it
doesn't look like a important pawn
necessarily but this pawn
once it falls we'll allow black to
attack the white rook so we're expecting
a trade and now might be the time to
kick back this knight from the center
you don't want to push it back with a
pawn because suddenly this knight will
find a dream outpost and outposts are
squares that cannot be challenged by the
opponent's pawns and also often
supported by
your own pawn so this knight would just
be a monster right now and it cannot be
allowed to infiltrate into white's camp
i think the most natural move would be
to develop the queen attacking the
knight in the process and if for example
the knight does retreat now we might see
magnus do something he did in the last
game against artemyev just start pushing
these pawns forward and uh
black does have the bishop pair
especially this black dart squad bishop
is going to be unchallenged on this
diagonal later on but in return black
does have a compromised pawn structure
these are double pawns in an end game
they're not going to be great and it
also means white has one extra central
pawn compared to black two versus one so
that's where magnus will play he'll push
forward in the center and this is what
i'm expecting at least to happen over
the next few moves we're expecting
bishop takes night and then maybe the
queen will start harassing this black
knight in the center obviously we can't
see magnus because his camera is down
but how do you think he's feeling about
the situation right now is this a game
that he will be enjoying playing right
now
yeah i don't think he'll be unhappy um
he doesn't necessarily have an advantage
um the evaluation bar is still kind of
undecided it still doesn't give much for
white so he won't be thinking about
whether he's better whether he's worse
whether he's on the defensive he'll just
be thinking okay it's a rich position
full of life
full of energy still all the pieces on
the board this end being a trade of one
set of pawns and that means
he can put his own stamp on the position
he can try his own ideas he will hope to
outmaneuver um abdusatorov and actually
the world rapid championship one area i
realized that abducator was doing very
well firstly in the openings he was very
well prepared but it was often when
things simplified where he could just
use his sharpness his resilience his two
move tactics here and there i've played
him online many times at blitz and in
terms of two three move tactics there's
not many player players quicker than him
so magnus he maybe just wants to keep
peace on the board and make it strategic
just slow and maneuvering so do you
think that is magnus's tactic when he's
facing now etc
would be my tactic pieces on the board
basically yeah and he didn't go for that
trade so maybe it is uh one of his
strategies he's brought his knight into
the center of the board now black's
knight both of black's knights are loose
both white's knights are loose but the
bishops have opened up so white's lights
go bishop hitting the black knight in
the center
suddenly there's some crazy tactics i'm
trying to work out what's about to
happen ivanka does that move surprise
you it surprises me for sure um i
actually i was actually thinking about
that move
i i just didn't want to suggest it so i
thought okay i i like your bishop takes
night but i i was i was thinking about
this move primarily because it is a
motif in a different positions with
slightly similar pawn structure and you
know they say loose pieces drop off but
i was trying to work out what's going to
happen with black so he tries to
reinforce that knight rather than move
it back i mean can he get away with that
okay so he retreats the night okay so
just to explain white's move um the
reason i was so shocked is because the
white knights now are are a bit loose
knights protecting each other they might
look very nice but actually if one of
them gets undermined the other one might
often fall so later on there might be
ideas such as pushing this pawn kicking
away this night and then suddenly the
other night will drop once it runs away
so um yeah the reasoning behind magnus's
move was to attack this knight simply
and ivanka mentioned trying to reinforce
it maybe bringing this bishop out but
that would be a bit loose as well maybe
this pawn could push forward so many
tactics so many loose pieces i'm not
sure whose pieces are going to drop off
but some pieces are definitely going to
drop off and that is why abductor have
decided okay time to play it safe
retreat the night and now okay we do see
a trade i'm surprised by that one
um it feels like magnus
he's rushing slightly with that knight
exchange i thought maybe you just leave
it and wait for black to exchange on
this square and you have a move in the
media that's what
very odd very odd and now he's taken
this knight two choices for abductor of
to take with the pawn or take with the
queen if he takes with the pawn i think
we'll see magnus now take this knight
okay this has happened so i'm expecting
magnus now to take this knight he has
done um and now again choices for black
if he takes this bishop the white knight
will simply step back and black has
these double pawns this white bishop is
great as well i think white has a small
advantage here not much but small and if
black goes for the other option of
taking this knight with his bishop then
we'll see magnus simply drop back and
actually this might be similar to his
game against tamif where he'll start
pushing central exactly and that looks
very unpleasant i mean for for white
again magnus will have all the long-term
trumps so you can see abdul
abdul satar of just simply goes okay
fine i'm going to have the bad pawn
structure but in return i'm going to
have
well dynamic play with the two bishops
yep and these pawns as we mentioned
doubled and not great uh it will be
difficult to create a pass pawn on that
left side of the board but then again
this bishop in particular very very
strong
now there's a pawn attacked and uh if
abdusatorov just takes the time out to
defend it for example with his own pawn
i think we'll see white's knight
re-maneuver
to a great square a nice outpost in the
center he will bring it forward and no
matter what black does next he'll plonk
it in the middle of the board and here
it cannot be challenged by any black
pawns he's also defended by white's
bishop and
this knight looking pretty good that's
why abdu satoru doesn't really have time
to just push pawns he brings his queen
forward instead he wants to create
threats with every move here he's
attacking a pawn because otherwise if he
allows white's knight to relocate to the
center to that magical d5 square that we
highlighted
white is simply doing well so okay
abdusto tour of trying to justify his
opening play with threats with dynamic
activity and uh actually there's a
serious question to magnus in the
following position that we have up on
the analysis board is how are you going
to defend that pawn that's under attack
because if you bit careless maybe maybe
black can actually trade the light
squared bishop that he has for the night
so i'm just thinking if you go rook that
square and then the light square bishop
can come out to the f5 square and say
woohoo
bishop takes knight that's a very
annoying pin as well because if white
ever wants to break that tension pushing
a pawn forward then black will happily
just step back and suddenly this pawn
blocks this white bishop it's all about
peace activity and white doesn't want to
block in his best pieces so i think
you're right your anchor even if white
actually wins a pawn in this position
it's not going to be great for white
because at some point you get kicked
back and then we see a trade and these
two pawns we talk about double pawns
they're useless they're basically just
one pawn opposite color bishops and uh
most likely leading to a draw so magnus
doesn't want to play passively he
doesn't want to go on the defense
instead he goes active
he's playing on the front foot going on
the counter attacks something that we
often well one can often forget when uh
they find their pieces attacked that yes
you actually have the possibility of
counter-attacking rather than passively
defending this is something that levon
aronia was fantastic in berlin yeah in
the grand prix yeah this one game
between level aronia and vincent kaima
who's also here that's one of the games
one of the best games i've seen in my
whole life just in terms of
counter-attacking yeah every move kaima
would the german player would attack
something of levons 11 would just leave
it and attack something of his and it
was just attack followed by country
attack attack counter attack attack
counter attack and in the end aronian
emerged victorious it was a crazy game
it absolutely was
but uh there's a this comes with a word
of warning when it comes to
counter-attacking you have to be able to
calculate all the consequences you can't
just counter attack for the sake of
counter-attack that's going to be easier
in classical chess than in rapid well
you have more time yeah yeah and it
comes from years of practice aronian
he's one of the most creative players in
the world but he's he's only got there
through training hard on calculation
um i remember in that game for example
his queen was attacked
he just ignored it just pushed upon to
attack his opponent's queen and this is
the type of thing that's happening here
just with lower stakes
magnus knew his pawn was attacked no
good way to defend it so
counter-attacking against black's pawn
and interesting i quite like it from
white but the computer doesn't i notice
very very surprising
i was going to say if queen takes poor
now white's knight does jump forward and
will leap forward into an even better
square in the center
that is the dream square um but you know
computers computers are computers they
play perfect chess and they can play in
their own little league and leave the
emotional chats and all the things that
and that's exciting exactly for us for
us humans and i can see a lot of lovely
selfies that you're all sending us and
keep them coming and use the hashtag
chesschamps and i just also wanted to
share with you on that subject of
selfies one that i particularly liked it
was comes from heidi the h porn who says
that they're ready for the air things
masters and uh thanks the champs chester
for the nice i found the winning move
mug from ascot
another one but uh this one also ha they
also had a bonus mug which was the chest
24 kara khan mag and they were just
there to say hello to me so also a big
hello to heidi and everyone yeah big
hello to everyone around the world uh
sending us selfies and uh following the
exciting chess here we're so excited
that all of you around the world are
joining us
in this very first day of the melt water
championship store and whoa look at the
bar yeah i finally got to say that today
it was going to happen it was going to
happen at some point and i'm surprised
as well i mean that looks like a very
sensible move for by uh abdusatorov i
would be shocked if it was a blunder i
don't think it's a blunder maybe just a
small strategic mistake but i'm
struggling to understand why black's
bishop has come out you mentioned this
plan ivanka that black bishop
it just wants to trade itself off for
white's night and therefore magnus has
run away with his knight to capture a
black pawn so temporarily at least
magnus is a pawn up
uh but then again look at the bar
what's happening undecided about what's
happening um
i'm trying to work out how black now can
try to destabilize the white knight and
the white rook protecting it if you can
kick away the white rook the white
knight might fall and it might drop off
the board so maybe black's light squad
bishop is going to take a step back to
attack that rook
suddenly it's really heating up there
are tactics there are tricks and
that is actually the best move we see
here stockfish the computer has three
suggestions but one is far better than
the others and on the board this store
finds it impressive stuff now should the
controller now find a less smiling
picture of magnus this is
is it dangerous for him right now it's
definitely dangerous and actually this
is really interesting we again see the
computer suggestions white rook now is
under attack from black's bishop
but the computer says the only way white
can hold the balance is by giving up his
rook for a bishop the rook worth five
the bishop worth three that is a big
sacrifice a big commitment to make the
computer just wants to move white's
queen across two squares or across just
one square to the left and
i think especially the computer's top
choice there queen to b1 that is barely
human that is going to be incredibly
difficult to find
indirectly
defending white's knight with the white
queen yeah
the only way the only way he's going to
find her is if he starts calculating the
rook moving along the fourth row keeping
an eye on the knight and if he works out
that maybe that's a fourth draw or maybe
even losing then he will look at other
options i mean we have seen on the 2021
tour that magnus was not shy of
sacrificing the exchange um a rook for a
bishop but
yeah here it's not just sacrificing
the queen onto that square that's tricky
yeah so just to explain why the
sacrifice is necessary as ivanka
mentioned the rook needs to stay on this
fourth rank to defend the knight next to
it uh you need to defend this knight if
you run away from the attack for example
if you step back the knight does fall to
the black queen the problem is where do
you put the rook no matter where you put
it you will get attacked for example by
a black pawn or even by the black bishop
and
sometime soon you will have to evacuate
the fourth rank that's why it's best to
just leave the rook here maybe just by
process of elimination magnus will
realize you can't really move this rook
to a safe square no matter where you
move you will just get attacked and
therefore the computer says bring the
queen across two squares but the reason
i think this is not human the reason i
think this is
so difficult to find is because you have
to see that your queen indirectly will
protect the white knight after the black
bishop captures your rook and you take
back to see that the queen opens up on
this line which was previously blocked
that is incredibly difficult i think
even if i had an hour on my clock i
would struggle to find a move like that
one so computers they do enlighten us
sometimes but that is incredibly tough
to find i think maybe the second choice
by the computer is slightly more natural
um so in this position just bring the
queen across one square
but after bishop takes rook queen
recaptures okay magnus didn't find any
of the top three moves there i was going
to say the queen protects the knight and
the game goes on but magnus he's giving
up the material in a different way and
now after dropping back the knight black
is simply going to take this rook
and then capture this pawn and
black is up a rook for a bishop and not
just that but this pawn long term look
at where it's going to promote to the
what black pawn is going to promote to
this square which is covered by the
black bishop and this has happened on
the board
magnus now i think he's in big big
trouble he's just plonked his bishop in
the center of the board nice square but
it's not enough compensation rooks are
going to be more important than the
bishop knight here and this black pawn i
think is just going to win the game long
term wow once it starts running it's
going to really sprint up the board
yeah that's uh no other words for it
that's the passer david yeah
like you say the most important thing is
that it can be escorted to the promotion
square by the dark square bishop um and
take a look at the coordination between
white's pieces you look at the rook
on next to the king look at the queen
still on her starting square take a look
at the potential of the black rocks they
can get motoring behind their own uh
past pawns i mean
so many lines magnus is i would say
eisen i was gonna say losing yeah quite
i think with best player for sure he's
losing but he will hope that his one
good piece in the position will give him
some compensation maybe later this pawn
will drop off maybe later some threats
against the black king but
uh i don't think it's going to be enough
i do satoru meanwhile just shuffling
across with his rook slightly surprising
because i thought his rook wanted to
back up this pawn later but he's just
keeping everything guarded black's
actually done the hard work black has
won material and
wow magnus is just trading queens
trading queens he's down on material and
he's just offering a trade and this is
such are you surprised he does not take
it yes yeah i would just say okay let's
get those queens off no more risk for
black and i'm just ahead of material but
after toro that's the reason he's the
world rapid champion and i'm not because
he he senses the dynamics better uh than
most players and now actually he's
gaining time hitting this undefended
pawn with his queen and maybe he's
realizing that actually
if you traded queens white's rook would
at least have jumped into the game for
example trade here and now white's rook
is activated with the bishop maybe the
white knight will jump in later on
yeah i actually like his decision better
than mine um
yeah keeping the queens on there's no
rush to trade it's human instinct when
you're up to simplify like a maths
equation trade off pieces hope your
extra material counts later on but this
queen is actually maybe at least for now
better than its counterpart wow but
that's kind of a sin in a way that you
make a you should always back up your
evaluation and your assumptions by
actual calculation you shouldn't just
assume you know like you say you know
queen takes queen where it takes queen
i'll be
better where mistakes happen and it
might not be a mistake there and then
but then you kind of carry on that
mentality throughout and uh you slip up
get lazy yeah and uh actually not just
is this pawn attacked but abdusatorov he
i think he's looked really deeply into
the position he's realized this is
white's best piece is supported and
protected by a pawn so next move if
white for example takes a time out to
just push this pawn or defend it then
black is going to undermine the defense
uh the defender of this bishop this pawn
now once he gets traded off uh which it
will then suddenly will lose protection
of this bishop this bishop will be
forced to step back retreat and white
will have no good pieces remaining
this one looks one-sided right now
abductor of a big favourite to win this
game wow and look at look at the clocks
as well
he's just uh crushing magnus as well on
the clocks right now yeah
quick confident
tricky resourceful he's got it all i've
disa tariff and uh yeah
i mean i was surprised i thought maybe
even with his performance in the world
rapid championship it will take him a a
tournament or two in on the tour just to
warm up just to get acclimatised to
playing these top guys
no nope nope nope a draw against geary
in the first game very nice result now
big big advantage against the world
champion
okay white's knight now blocking the
black's queen uh
it's diagonal but
it's temporary it's going to get kicked
away that white night soon and uh the
black queen's slowly improving himself
this is ice cold chasse you know i was
expecting black to perhaps utilize the
rook that's not in action but instead he
focuses on moving the queen and getting
ready to make that pawn break that you
suggested yep that black a pawn i think
last season on the tour we crowned her
uh we christened her alice
from alice in wonderland
but that black a pawn is just gonna
start running
kicking the white knight in the process
yeah the bar
sometimes we say we don't trust the
computer or the evaluation bar here we
can and we can because it says 1.7
but
okay now it changed but that was almost
17 and he's 17 years old
you're turning into a chess player
seeing those patterns everywhere
recognizing those numbers we always look
for those type of small signs uh yeah
and uh you can see absolutely
abductor off yeah you know in norwegian
because i followed of course the
norwegian show for the the rafter blitz
world championship and and in norwegian
you will say abdusattarov
and now i'm trying to switch to english
i'm the satorum
i'm just a toro
very posh yes it's very portion
it's uh yeah i mean
sorry no no no i was going to change the
topic completely me too so that was okay
i was just going to say the reason we
can't trust the evaluation by the
computer here is because if we do a
quick count of the material black simply
has a rook for a knight advantage and
that's a two-point advantage and here
the computer says 2.3 so that's why we
have this evaluation system the counting
system in chess um it's not always a
steadfast rule sometimes material is
less important than the actual quality
of the pieces but here
everything else is equal the rooks are
better than white's knight here so yeah
plus one plus two advantage minimum for
black and uh i have to say abdusatorov
is actually playing rather like magnus
you know following his philosophy
because magnus really believes in this
you know using all your pieces teamwork
makes a dream work and
there he is you know he's activating the
rook that wasn't in play
and he improves it before he initiates
any form of action
so magnus is kind of be going to be
feeling the heat and uh he pushes his
pawn one square forward i'm not quite
sure what it's doing but i think
anything goes in this position yeah i
guess magnus wants to push the pawn next
to it the white d-pawn forward two
squares to block the effect of black's
dark square bishop
it doesn't feel like it's
going to be that effective the plan it's
also a very slow plan
now black does have time for example i
was going to say to push pawns forward
kick back white tonight but magnus
simply had nothing else the one thing
i'll say in magnus's defense here is if
we rewind to the world championship
match i think it was game four against
the end of ponetti magnus kind of lost
slash blundered a rook for night and
there he held on to make a draw so yeah
let's not write him off yet
white white is in big big trouble here
but if anyone can save it it is magnus
carson and we see a trade of rooks black
in the meantime trying to trade off some
pawns
and there we go it was a trade but white
queen jumping in i'm wondering whether
abducator of underestimated this white's
two pieces are actually under fire now
the white bishop and white queen
attacked by sorry and white knight
attacked by black's queen but magnus
keeping things together with tricks oh
that is a nice tricky move because you
know it does look at first glance that
the white knight is on breeze but nope
there would be a nasty hidden check yeah
we have to show that yeah this is the
nastiest type of trick um just to show
what magnus did if we rewind a few moves
in this position it looks like big
trouble the bishop under attack the
white knight under attack as well magnus
counter-attacked we talked about that
earlier he counter-attacked so now if
the black queen moves if she captures
either of these two pieces the black
rook would fall um so black's rook a bit
loose here he decided to run away
protecting this pawn near the king and
now after queen takes pawn the trap
javanco mentioned if queen takes knight
getting greedy greed is punished by
bishop takes pawn check hitting the
black king and next move we realize that
the black queen is under fire a
discovered attack against the black
queen so yeah big big trap in the
position there but i do satoru he's
sharp he sees these things so quickly
and he just ignored this knight which is
not actually up for grabs he just pushed
his pawn and this pawn now only three
squares away from promotion it's not
going to be easy to get there but if it
does it's protected by the black bishop
it can actually get there right now if
uh white is a little bit careless so
white plays a non-move i don't know
yeah for instance that you can actually
push the pawn right now because hey that
queen is a big big defender of the
bishop and uh you white just cannot
capture that runaway pawn yep if uh
white does capture then suddenly the
bishop does fall and that would be game
over instantly so actually you're right
ivanka um i kind of wrote it off after
this pawn push i thought okay the white
queen is defending this square the white
bishop is defending this square the
black pawn isn't going anywhere
anywhere soon but
maybe with those tricks with those ideas
black can just by brute force
push this pawn forward and
yeah it's now slightly less material
deficit for white white has worn a pawn
over the last few moves so now it's a
knight in pawn for the black rook but
it's all about this guy and this pawn
looking very very scary also the clock
magnus down to two minutes you never
will you normally never see him in this
situation down on the clock by so much
it's uh looking very very good for black
here we could have the first big
shocking result here in the meltdown
champions chess store coming up if the
17 year old making his debut in the tour
is able to beat the world champion now
levon aronian winning two games in a row
now uh winning also his game against
alexander kostenyk so that's two wins so
far after two rounds four levonaronian
great start yeah he's a man on fire i
think one of the in-form players of the
year definitely yeah
doing great also in the grand prix where
he came second yeah and last season
actually the second half of the tour he
was one of the most impressive live on
aronian yeah uh magnus said it himself
something about him just clicked he was
playing so speedy so fast
treating his opponents like they were
passes as we say in chess like players
he was just showing them no respect and
that was paying off his opponents would
get scared and crumble he really did
figure out that online rapid chess thing
just uh you know he's a fantastic chess
player he was in the start of the season
as well but just the format he just uh
figured it out and just crushed it and
he also kind of changed style because i
i've kind of christened him like mr
center you know take the center and uh
just develop the pieces and instead he
was playing all sorts of like quirky
openings and he would consistently ask
his opponents hey what you gonna do and
he would always do this
by playing quickly on the clock as well
and uh on the board it's magnus who is
very clearly suffering because that past
porn alice is runaway train and she's
really gonna push forward two squares to
her destination
i don't see anything
ah yeah it's really backs to the wall
from magnus carson his last move i like
it for white he's blunted the effect of
that black bishop that black bishop now
has lost connection to the promotion
square of that black pawn
and meanwhile temporarily
temporarily at least by tonight white's
bishop they do prevent the advance of
black's pawn but
it looks like a short-term measure
white's pieces are a bit loose they all
defend each other right now but
as long as you dislodge one of those
pieces i think the others might get
kicked away as well so black's rook can
actually move right now
so which square it should choose but uh
the black could move so the move that
i'm really tempted to play i don't know
whether it works i need some calculation
it's actually to move the rook along the
c line okay because white's king is not
that safe there's a lot of
air around the king shall we say and
feeling very lonely it is feeling very
lonely and my instinct here and i
haven't backed up with any calculation
is to move this and i just want to see
if black can get a bit fruity so that
when the white knight jumps in to block
that line maybe he can just go hey i
know you're threatening to go night
check but maybe i can actually
switch my pawn
wow okay interesting so pushing this
pawn hoping to deflect the white bishop
and then just capture this white knight
now there there does that does involve
the calculation because there's checks
involved in the game but okay instead we
see a different approach from adusa
toronto yeah i liked your move actually
i must say much more ivanka instead
abductor has played his bishop to this
square that's sneaky it looks like the
bishop is about to drop it looks like
it's a loose square but suddenly the
white queen would be deflected away and
the white knight would fall and actually
i think the white knight is needed to
stop the advance of this pawn so this
exchange would favor black but after the
bishop moved
it wasn't captured and black white just
dropped his bishop back magnus now
firmly blockading this pawn and wow i
was going to say abdu torah has to take
a time out protect his bishop but no
he's so sharp so sneaky so tricky
bringing his queen back and now
undermining the white queen now the
white queen has a decision to make if
she takes this bishop the knight falls
so she couldn't go for this also no
trade possible here if you take the
queens off the board the black rook is
simply going to come down and dislodge
the white bishop so okay very
clever move there uh by abdushotorov
ingenius in a way but now white stepping
back
what's going to happen here if the black
rook attacks the white queen it looks
like all of white's pieces are really
hanging by a thread now
i mean the queen is needed to protect
this knight which is needed to protect
this bishop it's all i mean it's like a
pack of cards if you knock one over the
rest might fall as well like domino's
even but
maybe magnus can keep this together with
tricks maybe he can jump forward with
his knight to block the attack against
his queen
i don't like it for white still but
there's no killer blow yet
magnus defending like a lion
in this game and you still have to
remember that the black king is a little
bit by itself
a little bit vulnerable in the light
squares so i think magnus is maybe
dreaming about
aligning the queen and bishop on the
same diagonal and uh trying to do
something that's why maybe a satori
decided to move his king forward off
this diagonal but
yeah you mentioned kaya
yeah this does feel a bit slow it feels
like black has just retreated the queen
sometimes you can justify a retreat if
you have more active moves coming next
but then he took another timeout a
second time out just to improve his king
and
i'm trying to work out why this is a
mistake maybe the white knight can jump
in now
there we go actually
white has several night moves that might
cause some annoyance to black white has
three night moves as we see stockfish
the computer's suggesting now this may
be the most natural it does happen in
the position suddenly there are some
threats against the black king side this
black bishop on a very loose square i
didn't like putting it there in the
first place and now i'm trying to work
out what would happen after the rook
comes across to attack the white queen
but then it looks like these pieces
protecting each other the white queen
could eliminate the dangerous black pawn
and
suddenly it's anyone's game suddenly
white might be the one with the momentum
so in the current position a big big
threat queen takes pawn but also maybe
knight takes bishop how does abdusatorev
defend against both
not easy anymore just one slip and the
world champion is right back in it
magnus fighting still so hard wow
there's a lot of danger in the position
um i do like magnus's move but uh the
first move that comes to mind for black
is actually okay let's just go in with
the queen
let's gamble absolutely everything and
bank on some counter-attacking
possibilities so that after knight takes
bishop you're like ah i am not taking
that knight i'm going to take this would
be disastrous
that would be bad and instead just go
queen takes bishop but then the queen
will slide itself across two squares and
lining itself up and suddenly check
mating ideas in the air and the queen
knight dangerous combination yeah the
knight does the only type of maneuver
that the queen cannot and that makes
them a fearsome duo they combat they
combine so so well actually here i would
be terrified with black that i would be
getting checkmated the what the black
queen looks great but she's offside
she's not actually helping um the
fighter for example if the black queen
retreats trying to trade off then the
white knight would leap forward and a
double attack black king has to move and
more nasty checks in the air and while
this might actually happen wow we see a
turn around uh the black queen has
jumped in magnus now has no choice he
simply has to capture this bishop i
think
he has to go on the counter attack
because his own bishop is about to fall
um no time to move it so knight takes
bishop queen takes and actually while
you were um talking there ivanka i
realized maybe there's a way to force a
draw if white once maybe white wants
more but maybe you can even go knight
check attacking the black king the black
king has to keep protecting its rook and
if you take this knight
check
king moves another check the king moves
another check and this would end the
game in a repetition a draw
nice line to escape and uh very very
thematic but uh let's go back to the
position where the knight and the queen
are aligned together
okay
bishop
queen takes bishop and now the move okay
he's gone for the win not taking the
draw magnus carlsen he's aligned his
queen with the black king okay
how to defend yeah i mean this just
double check that you mentioned how on
earth are we gonna do it i mean it's
it's
maybe the king can hide itself i have an
idea king can hide itself not on the
back row
but on the h6 square i don't think you
want to run that immediately because
there would be a checkmate no not that
not immediately but
yeah next move yeah that's that's my
safe place so what i want to do is okay
so first of all i have to check with the
queen on the light square okay and the
king moves forward and now the queen
will dash back and offer a trade okay
and now the white knight i guess i'm
trying to choose a square maybe this one
still so a double attack as we mentioned
and then the king can hide itself on
this the sixth row yeah and then there
would be a check and if the king takes
this knight oh no i'm going to get
checkmated again
queen takes pawn
and a checkmate so white would actually
be a whole rook down but the king would
be trapped and wow are we heading
towards this in the current position
okay he's given a check on a different
square this move would have lost i think
but he's checked on this square hitting
the white king
how will white block white will push
this pawn to block or this pawn or this
pawn i'm not sure which one
you can move any of these three pawns to
block this check let's just use a random
one okay let's say this one's the most
advanced pawn let's push exactly
i also want to use the queen to maybe
guard against this pawn later and now
black still has this big issue how to
okay magnus actually goes for that block
and now how to deal with this technique
ah now now because he's pushed that
particular pawn the queen can actually
defend against the checkmate by putting
herself on the b2 square long range
defense
clever yeah so using the queen on this
diagonal to
stop any potential checks and maybe this
yeah it's happened ivanka you found it
maybe the only defense for abductor of
because now a knight check a double
check uh for example this double check
forcing the king to move um would not
end in disaster for black anymore
because this square which was previously
used by the white queen is actually
covered by black's queen from afar
wow really really sneaky defense there
really clever defense and that means
magnus has to check with his knight any
double check you have to move your king
and it steps back and we're going to see
a draw let's go back to abductor off
we're going to see a repetition of the
position and we actually have magnus
back as well for the first time in the
game
but just in time for the position to
repeat itself yeah
wow uh uh how impressed are you with
magnus that he was able eventually to
save this which he probably is about to
do yeah very very impressed i mean full
credit to of de satoru just one slip
really let magnus back in the game but
apart from that he played perfectly and
wow more credit to him because he's not
going for the draw he wants to win whoa
this is risky i kind of wrote it off
because now there was no more check with
the white knight
but the problem is black's king is still
in big big trouble and white's knight
and queen now combining attacking the
black rook the black rook has to move
but where do you move it to
oh this is playing with fire with black
yes black has this amazing pawn on the
left side but he's not getting time to
push it what happens if you try to just
offer up the rook for
for grabs
can you do that where do you put it
though i want to put it where on a
square where it's under attack okay um
do you attack the white queen to the b8
square is the one i wanted wow i wanted
to move that knight away
because that that white knight is a
little bit annoying you know it's got it
it's kind of operating within its super
power zone you know with the knight
jumping from squares
octo knight as we kind of call it
and yeah actually we might still see the
position repeat itself white using the
queen and knight together trying to get
to the black king but black's rook is
able to just kind of yo-yo back and
forth away from the attack of the white
knight then back to protect its king
away from the attack back to protect its
king and the position should still
repeat itself i've do so tour of with no
time left either so
yeah i think it now is the time to
accept the draw and magnus still begging
for that repetition in a way but he's
going to get it he's going to save this
game
and there we see now magnus leaps
forward with the knight he shrugs his
shoulders that's the third time we've
seen this position it's a draw wow and
okay well we can see both players sort
of a sigh of relief there for magnus and
the smile he did get away with the draw
here